Gail is writing and we have an
anti-aging cream business that we tried
several years ago to advertise he's
basically doing a whole bunch of stuff
she tried advertising trade shows she's
trying to do it in social media but
she's not getting any luck how can she
promote this business of hers to start
getting some results in social yeah I
think I didn't specifically thought but
let me never take its tab I think with
Nancy aging cream you know obviously
what it would offer is what's the
benefit and it's all about well then
it's all about I guess self-confidence
and self you know I have and I look at
you and I'm an old guy you're a young
guy you got all the Edit though um if
this product could like me all the guys
and girls around the world said actually
it will look after my whirlwind looks
after my skin it produces extra
allergies all those sort of things then
yeah I like that and I think the way to
do it is with all these things kind of
start small build a community of fans
and then kind of go and through social
you can go awesome and then with tryouts
like anti-aging creams you know the
website is a shop window on the world
but how you do it i think is it's all
about kind of social referrals and these
things do go buy recommendation and you
know things like aging creams beauty
products is a fantastic market where
recommendations and referrals are create
viral success and unless so start small
maybe go out to community of friends in
your village get test drive the product
come up with a few references to a few
video clips of how it's made a
difference there like put it online open
up a kind of web store and I think yeah
I think as a solid York if you're trying
to get it on Twitter and it's not having
luck I think if we were to look at your
Twitter feed it would probably just
super promotional and spammy right
there's no value there there's no story
there's no core you know stand up for
something around aging that's important
to you I think how do you sell in social
most people do the wrong thing they're
just broadcasting all the time pushing
out coupon codes or whatever and nobody
pays any attention we're how you should
do it is look at
this is an example right now we are
social selling right now through our
values even though i'm not talking about
any products Stevens not Stevens not
coming on in saying hey you guys need to
go by sage software it's the best thing
for your business and wait there's more
if you do it right now on this hangout
you're going to get ten percent off your
first month right you know if he were
doing that you guys would all take off
right and i would probably hang up to
he's coming on and giving value right
he's talking about what he's doing with
the librarian in davos and trying to
help you like he's got 15,000 employees
to worry and about and he's on here
chatting with you trying to help you
grow your business because he cares
because this is something that's
meaningful to him right and something
that meaningful to me too why am i
spending my time because i want to help
you guys out too and so if you think
about it though the next time that you
need accounting software right you're
all entrepreneurs or you're going to
start your business when you need
accounting software who's the first
company you're going to go to write its
sages business to lose because of all
the value that steven has given you to
help your business and that and that's
how it works and you see the results is
companies are exploding leading the
stock market back to the black and i
think that's how you do it you want to
sell on social that's the key right
start sharing your passion start
providing value start being the expert
don't just talk about your anti-aging
cream because that's a commodity that i
can buy in a lot of places make me have
a reason to want to buy from you because
i know you'd like you trust you and
you're the first person i'm going to go
to you have to then lose my business
because i love you so much with
everything that you're putting out
that's how you win social and that's how
you make sales to not just spamming out
links